given the
complexity all cosmological scales
involved here the led to the extinction
of the dinosaurs when you look out at
the future of Earth do you worry about
future Extinction events I I do think
that we might be in the middle of an
Extinction right now if you define it by
the number of species that are getting
killed off and it's subtle but you know
it's a complex system the way things
respond to events is sometimes things
evolve sometimes animals just move to
another place and the way we've
developed the Earth it's very hard for
species just to move somewhere else and
we're seeing that with people now too I
mean I know people are worried just
about AI taking over and that's a
totally different story we just don't
think about the future very much we
think about what we're doing now and we
certainly don't think enough about all
the animals that we're destroying all
the things that are precursors to humans
that we sort of rely on
it's interesting to to think whether the
the the things that threaten us is the
stuff we see that's happening gradually
or the stuff we don't really see that's
going to happen all of a sudden I
sometimes like think about what is what
should we be more worried about because
it seems like like with the asteroids or
nuclear war it could be stuff that just
happens one day you know when I say one
day meaning over a span of a few days or
a few months
but on a you know not on a scale of
decades and
centuries CU we sometimes mostly talk
about stuff that's happening
gradually but you can be really
surprised it's actually really
interesting and that was actually one of
the reasons it took a while to determine
what it was that had caused the last
extinction because people did think at
the time of many people thought that
things were more gradual and the idea of
Extinction was a very was actually a
novel concept at some point
I mean these aren't predictable events
necessarily they're only predictable on
a grand scale um but sometimes sometimes
they are and and I think people were
pretty aware that nuclear um weapons
were dangerous I'm not sure people are
as aware now as they were you know say
20 or 30 years ago and that certainly
worries me um I have to say I was not as
worried about AI as other people but now
I understand and it's not
I mean it's more that as soon as you
create things that we lose control over
it's scary and the other thing that
we're learning from the events today is
that is that it takes a few bad actors
it takes everyone to sort of make things
work well it takes not that many things
to make things go wrong it's it's the
issue with disease you know we can find
out what causes a disease but to make
things better is not necessarily that
simple sometimes it is but for things to
be healthy a lot of things have to work
for things to go wrong only one thing
has to go wrong and so it's amazing that
we do it and the same is true for
democracy for democracy to work a lot of
people have to believe in it a few bad
actors can destroy things sometimes so a
lot of the things that we really rely on
are delicate equilibrium situ some of
you know and there is some robustness in
the systems we try to build in
robustness but a few extreme events can
sometimes alter things and um I think
that's what people are scared of today
in many ways they're scared of it for
democracy they're scared of it for peace
they're scared of it for AI I think
they're not as scared as they should be
about nuclear weapons to be honest um I
think that's a more serious danger Than
People realize um I think people are a
little bit more scared about pandemics
than they were before um but I still say
they're not super scared about it so
you're right there are these major
events that can happen and we are
setting things up so that they might
happen and we should be thinking about
them the question is who should be
thinking about them how should we be
thinking about them how do you make
things happen on a global scale because
that's really what we need it certainly
shouldn't be a source of division it
should be a source of grand
collaboration probably wouldn't that be
nice yeah I just wonder what it would be
like a to be a dinosaur it must have
been beautiful to like look at the
asteroid just enter the atmosphere until
like everything just man would I
that would be one of the things I would
travel back in time to you know that's
also one of the things that I think you
probably could do with virtual reality I
don't think you have to be there and get
extin just experience it I think there's
something you know it's an event you're
just watching you're not doing anything
you're just looking at it so maybe you
could just recreate it I actually heard
that there a there's a nuclear weapon
explosion experience in virtual reality
that's good to remind you about like
what it would I have to say you know so
I got I got an award from the Museum of
nuclear history and technology in the
southwest and I went to visit the museum
which turned out to be mostly a museum
of nuclear weapons and the scary thing
is that they look really cool you know
it's true that you have that yes this is
scary but you also have this this is
cool feeling and I think we have to get
around that because yeah I kind of think
that yes you can be in that but I'm not
sure that's going to make people people
scared has it have they actually asked
afterwards are you more or less scared
yeah that's a good uh it's a really good
point I mean that's a good summary of
just Humanity in general
we attracted to creating cool stuff even
though it's can be dangerous and
actually that was the really interesting
thing about visiting that museum
actually it was very nice because I had
a tour from people who had been working
there in the cold war and actually one
or two people from the Manhattan Project
it was a very cool tour and you just
real realiz just how just the thing
itself gets you so excited I think
that's something that sometimes these
movies Miss just the thing itself you're
not thinking about the the overall
consequences and it was kind of like in
some ways it was like the early Silicon
Valley you know people were just
thinking like what if we did this what
if we did that and you know not take
keeping track of like what the
peripheral consequences are and you
definitely see that happening with AI
now I mean I think that was the moral of
the battle that just happened that you
know it's just Full Speed Ahead
which gives me a really great transition
to another quote in your book so you you
write about it the experience of facing
the sublime in physics and you quote uh
Ryan
aril quote for beauty is nothing but the
beginning of Terror which we are still
just able to endure and we're so OD
because it serenely disdains to
annihilate us it's pretty intense it I
think applies to nuclear weapons but it
also I mean at a more mundane perhaps
level I think it applies you know it's
really interesting one of the things I
found when I wrote these books is you
know some people love certainty you know
scientists kind of many Revel in
uncertainty it's not that you want to be
uncertain you want to solve it but
you're at this Edge where it's really
frustrating because you don't really
want to not know the answer but of
course if you knew the answer that would
be it would be done so you're always at
this Ed Edge where there's you're trying
to sort things out and there is
something scary you don't know what is
you don't know if there's going to be a
solution you don't know if you're going
to find it so it's not something that
can destroy the Earth it's just
something that you do on your individual
level but then of course there are much
bigger things like the ones you're
talking about where they could actually
be dangerous the stuff I do I just want
to be clear I'm doing theoretical
physics not very dangerous um but
sometimes things end up having bigger
consequences than you think yeah but
dangerous in a very pragmatic sense but
isn't it still in part terrifying when
you think of a just the size of things
like the size of dark matter like the
the the power of this thing in terms of
uh it's his potential gravitational
effects just this cosmological objects
of a black hole at the center of our
galaxy so this might be why I'm a
physicist or why I differ from other
people yeah because I'm not such a big
fan of humanity in some ways some ways I
am but the idea that we were everything
would be really boring to me I love the
idea that there's so much more out there
that there's a bigger universe and
there's lots to discover and that we're
not all there is wouldn't it be
disappointing if we were all there is
yeah and and the the full diversity of
other stuff it's pretty interesting you
know we have no idea how much there is
you know we we know what we what we can
observe so far so the idea that there's
other stuff out there that we yet have
to figure out it's
exciting